clark county is working right now to
build a permanent memorial for one
october it's separate from the healing
garden downtown
and today we're getting a better idea of
what it could look like hector mejia is
live in our newsroom with those details
hi hector
hey there we've covered this since the
very beginning since the one october
committee had its first meeting five
months ago and i was appointed by the
county to gauge public opinion
for a memorial site the goal is to
create something permanent honoring
victims survivors first responders and
the community
well today committee members went over
results from a 15 question survey
almost 6 100 people responded the
committee is trying to figure out where
to build a memorial
most respondents a combined 65.5 percent
want it to go
at the site of the route 91 harvest
festival shooting on the las vegas strip
survivors are the ones who felt most
strongly about that location
and around 17 percent opposed those were
people who reported suffering ptsd or
who lost a loved one
some also gave their own suggestions
mentioning possible performance space
and
opportunities for quiet reflection a
small number
said they don't even want a memorial my
hope
is that at the end of it even if
you know there are different individuals
that
aren't completely happy with the result
they at least know that they did have
um that engagement with us
and did have their voice heard the
committee also
chose a logo to represent them the one
with a purple heart
survivors identified with the purple and
orange colors those were a part of the
branding of the festival
and we've covered this you know since
very beginning and people were also
asked
what kind of experience they'd like the
top four terms were healing
peace respect and community this was
just the first step there will be more
surveys and possibly
future town hall meeting hector mejia
reporting 8 news now